hi thank you so much for coming to my
session I really appreciate you coming
taking your time my name is leta and i'm
here to talk to you about distributed
tracing I work on the networking team at
lyft and these are one of like the main
observability tools that we use to look
into what's happening with our system
and I hope at the end of this talk it's
morally meant for people who are not
really experienced with just should be
tracing or they don't have it quite yet
and they want to know what it is and at
the end of the talk I hope that you have
a good idea of what it is and they can
take it with you and to like your work
and at your company before I dive in to
what tracing is I want to talk give a
little bit background about myself so I
worked at live four years ago and I
started off as an application developer
working on lyft line just when it
launched and so I built a lot of
features there and helped it launch to
nation wide and then after a year I
switched into infrastructure and there I
would help decompose our model ax to
micro services but also decided to go
into cogeneration and like try to make
communicating between micro services a
lot more efficient a lot more easier and
we use protocol buffers to do that by
generating a bunch of code for a lot of
different languages it's just pretty fun
but before then I switched into
networking and got into distributed
tracing before all of that before I
joined lyft I used to work at DreamWorks
Animation of creating tools for artists
and different production tools for
specific movies I've also worked on
Madagascar 3 which is the most popular
movie I worked on and overall the the
throughout my career I think I'm really
motivated by making really useful
developer tools and making people more
productive and that's why I got really
excited about tracing because I think it
enables people to discover data and
figure out where to pull up
their efforts so yeah so this is like
the overall agenda for the talk I want
to start off by giving an overview of
what distributed tracing is and I
started off with like the visualization
aspect like why the UI is really cool
and like how it displays data in a
different way than metrics and logging
and then I go into how to add this to
application so what does the
instrumentation code look like what is
the how does the data get collected so
there are many tools out there but I'll
describe like one way to do it um there
are many ways but they're all kind of
similar they're kind of architectures
and similar instrument sorry so they're
all similar in in collection and
instrumentation and then the second part
of the talk I go into how lyft
integrated because we didn't really
start off building which way like
tracing from the ground up we actually
migrated towards it we had a lot of
micro services and trying to integrate
them as like a midsize company had some
interesting challenges and some
learnings I wanted to pass off with you
to you if you decide to go on this
venture so before we can go into
distributed tracing I want to give
context to what we had before and the
current observability tools out there so
first and foremost is metrics this is
the main way that lift engineers monitor
their services if they're very cheap you
fire them off on your application at the
bottom there I have a little snippet of
Python code that shows how you would
fire off a stat like a counter and
usually we use this to measure like
error rates network saturation and
throughput and CPU and memory usage and
it's really they're very cheap to store
so like as your system scales your
intensity in terminating a counter it
doesn't get any more expensive and
what's really nice is that like when you
look at a graph you could see change
it's really easy to see anomalies so
people really love their graphs and like
my watching them as they deploy or
watching them day-to-day and seeing if
there's any issues the second form of
observability tools that the fuses was
logging heavily so we ingest them into
elastic search and search out of cabana
it's very typical and at the bottom I
show you how one would instrument in an
application a log and this is very
useful to triage once you see a problem
you go into your logs and search for
errors and see what's happening and
they're used in to display stack traces
as well as unexpected code paths so it's
it was like it was more of like metrics
and logics work together where we would
monitor looking at dis dashboards but
then go into logs to figure out what's
wrong if something was to go wrong so
this talk is not about why that how
distributed chasing is like better than
metrics or logging and it's not about
that at all I think they're great the
metrics and logging are really great
tools and they're not going away at all
but the but the issue with these tools
is that they tell a story from a
perspective of one application so you
have like and you have to have a lot of
context of that application to get the
most out of these tools and this
actually worked pretty well because
especially in the early days of lyft
when we were a big monolith so
transactions happen in the same computer
so all the request response was
contained in one process and the stat
you could stat in log and debug from
that perspective and since it's coming
from one application that worked
perfectly well but now as we move
towards like a micro services
architecture that was no longer the case
so now requests can go through multiple
computers go through multiple network
hops and that all the observability data
is coming from many different sources
and for a while we just we added a
request ID or a write ID to kind of tie
that data to
yeah they're in our locks to kind of
solve this problem uh it to end like be
able to aggregate that way and so I
wanted to go through like an example of
what that looked like when we started
moving towards micro-services how
engineer would debug an issue with that
meant method this is a common flaw I
used to do in the early days of lift
we're like let's say a client reported
issue or like a support ticket or like
there's a spiking 500 I'm trying to
figure out what's going on so start off
with searching by that indicator like I
was be able to find a right ID that it
affected and search by that right ID and
then I noticed that like okay there
these are the micro services this is
talking to like it's it is look bucketed
ties by ASG and and then I noticed that
like these are the time stamps these are
it goes from like newest newest to
oldest so I could see here that uh or
this request started talking to our
front poxy which is envoy and then went
to public API and the rights API and the
API service and this is essentially
informing this kind of service
dependency diagram in my mind this is
like this is kind of what's happening my
brain to connect all the pieces like
okay this is a flow of the request this
is what's happening as I'm debugging
through and this kind of worked pretty
well for a while especially when we were
like only ten services however now we
are no longer two services we are now
nine hundred services and a request can
go through 20 through 20 and 30 of these
things and one request is very typical
to have like 200 plus RPC Clause that's
very normal and if I were to continue
the way that I was debugging before I
would just be shifting through a bunch
of log like pages and pages of logs
which is not really a useful great use
of my time and so and even even it like
so again this is way too much to fit in
my brain like there's no way till is
there a better way to display this data
and it that it shows me what I care
about
and there are it certain certain answers
of this with logging right so you could
learn a better you could learn the query
language so query just for errors but
still like neat questions like what does
this request what services does this
request depend on or like where are the
like what what service is taking the
longest like out of this whole request
the latency is really long what joint is
the bottleneck here those are harder
questions to answer with logging and
metrics kind of just have like you it
feels like those tools are not designed
to answer those kinds of questions
because they're designed to show you
data in the perspective of the
application not necessarily the request
so that's what distributed tracing is
trying to solve is trying to create a
different kind of tool where it shows
you with it shows you the data in the
request in mind
not necessarily the application so here
is a trace view that same trace view
from the Logging's
turned into a distributed trace and I've
I've I'm like hiding some UI elements
here like the metadata that shows but
ultimately this is is essentially it and
so I want to get through some vocabulary
terms before I move on to it with a talk
so this whole view is what's called a
trace and each row is a span and here
where you see the Envoy emitted a span
and a span contains timing data so it
always has a start an end time and it
has and it's known as the unit of work
so the up there is a operation name and
the operation is called egress or like
sent off a request and it has a
component name which is the service name
in this case in the front and the top
one its envoy so it's started as fires
off a span and within that span it fires
up like it called public API so creates
an estes man called public api and then
as you can see it calls nested calls
necess bands
further down and in lifts case we create
a span for both ingress which is the
network coming in and the egress
call-out and what's nice about this view
is that its latency in mind so the
longer the span the longer the request
took and those fans are tied together by
span context --is so the I would like to
think of it as a graph like a dag so a
directed acyclic graph or the where each
node is a span and they are tied
together by the spanked on Texas which
is essentially identifier that ties them
together so here is a a more simple
example that I made in order to
reiterate some examples of why this view
is very useful so we have a client a web
server and this web server talks is two
small micro services and does a database
call and here you can see the client is
the root span and let me show you that
he'll show you how the whole from the
clients point of view how long the
request response took and the web server
it's you it's work contains like calling
the ah service and then calling the
billing service and does some concurrent
processing current work and then writes
that result into a database so like
let's say the date like those let's say
the crime reported like 500 and then
you're trying to figure out why with
this view like you can eat like you
there's a way for you to mark not span
as an error and it'll just show up as
red and with this you can easily see the
oh something's wrong with the database I
could go investigate I could go look at
the logs for that database to see what's
wrong
versus like when the client reported
five hundreds you look into web server
like I don't see any errors in my code
like you have to go searching for them
in the logs a lot hurt takes more energy
to figure out where the root problem is
versus this view shows exactly where
where you should focus your efforts
the second useful thing that um that
I've seen that lift that tracing is very
useful for is like doing these
performance optimizations so let's say
you're exploring around and looking at
different traces and your system and you
see that the building service is calling
a the user data repeatedly like three
times and it's that same exact same user
data so here you realize oh that's not
very efficient because say do some
optimizations here so that we think we
should introduce some caching so that we
don't call the database three times so
those are the kind of things that
tracing
tracing affords where you can like
explore the data and see these weird
patterns that people add as code changes
like so frequently you can easily see
like optimizations like these that you
can make to your service so yeah these
things are great like you get root cause
analysis you get service dependent you
get you can see what the reservist is
that the request depends on you can see
you can do some performance analysis
here like how do you add this to the
system it must be very expensive or very
hard to or like must be very
time-consuming to add and there was a
couple of challenges for adding
instrumentation at lift one the biggest
one is the fact that we have a polygon
microservices architecture so we support
services and go we support services in
Python Java and PHP secondly it's we
ideally don't want product engineers to
think about instrumentation or have them
do the instrumentation the main the main
reason for this is that it's really hard
to get them to change their code
especially if it's not for the purposes
of building the feature because they're
incentivize who should product features
and secondly if they don't see the
immediate benefit it's it's hard to sell
them on and unfortunately fortunately or
unfortunately traces get more useful as
more in services
instrument with them so it's like one
application I'd assume it's was tracing
that's not as useful as if everyone does
similar it's kind of like a network
effect where like um like for the
typical example it's a telephone so if
like I only have a telephone it's not
very useful but everyone has a telephone
it gets exponentially useful we also
don't want engineers to make mistakes
with especially with timing and like the
naming we want we want we want to
standardize how you name things like you
want the component name to be the
service name you want the operation to
be a representative name that like is
easily searchable without necessarily
the engineer knowing what the your code
looks like and we really like how do you
enforce standardization with these
things so like we again like the ideal
scenario is that you not everyone needs
to know what your application is doing
but they could still find usefulness in
your trace isn't kind of for what what
that span is doing and so the other like
another thing that people have brought
up as you could monkey patch so like
that doesn't really work and go but in
Python in Java you can inject code or
you can monkey patch how you process a
network request
unfortunately that really doesn't scale
because one like if there's errors or
bugs in that code like it's hard to
figure out what's going on and product
engineers don't like things changing
from under them it's not an ideal
situation and when you're trying to ramp
up new engineers who were to work on
this code it's it's harder to teach them
what's going on it's better to be more
explicit for maintainability and lastly
we don't want vendor lock-in
so there's many tracing tools out there
the one I just show you is live status
which is the provider paid provider we
use but there's open source options as
well so like we don't want to be locked
into one instrumentation and then like
that's what we're stuck waited for the
and like to migrate over will be painful
so I
in a way where we can like pick and
choose depending on like what the needs
of the business are so that's what open
tracing is trying to solve so open
tracing is a specification or an
interface that you use so that your
instrumentation code doesn't change then
you swap out your vendor in your
initialization step what's nice about
this is that it creates a
standardization for the data model and
it because it's an interface you're
forced to give it the start and end time
'information as well as the operation
and component names it's open sourced
it's maintained supported by the native
cloud computing foundation and then and
it has a lot of activity so they have
support from many languages for
especially all the ones that live
support such as go Python and Java yes I
mentioned mention that and what's nice
it's also its vendor neutral so what it
does is that it creates interface
between the application of how its
instrumenting and sending data and then
it has an interface for the vendor side
to collect the data so that's always
like both parties adhere to the
interface they play well together so I
have an example here for in Python of
how one would instrument with open
tracing so first you would when you
start up your application you would
initial it is your tracer like so and I
have two examples of initializing the
tracer in two different ways one is
through the light step collector and the
second is the Jager the Jager tracer
tracing tool which is an open source
tool and then this is the actual
instrumentation portion so we have like
a simple endpoint called - format and
this three lines is the only tracing
code you need - this is the only like
open tracing code that you need to add
into your code that's like required so
here what it's doing is it looks at the
head so how it passes that that
identifier that's band contacts is
through network headers
so it looks at the headers to see if
there is one if there isn't that means
it's a route span so it will start up a
new span and it will start this is
specific to Python but basically
anything within that nested in that with
statement it's timed so it'll start up
the spare and calls format and it'll
pass in this end context if there is one
and that way it that's how it stores
that really parent-child relationship
and it's not actually and then there's
extra options so you could add a meta
data to that you get meta data as well
but for the most part that's all that's
really required to omit a span which is
not that much code and here is like an
example of the Jaeger architecture where
basically you have the application the
instrumentation code and for Jaeger they
run a little agent on the side as a
sidecar process which then sends the
data to the collectors and they store
their tracing data in a Cassandra
database and the UI just makes queries
directly from that database this is
pretty this is kind of typical for most
tracing tools that you some use Kafka to
like ingest the data and then the Kafka
will publish that data to a collector
but for the most part the data goes to a
collector and then stores that in a
database and the UI queries it directly
from the database and what's really
powerful is that the application has no
idea what client you're using it doesn't
really care you could swap this portion
out with anything else
and like when Zipkin or a haystack or
light step so that that's pretty
powerful however so it's not that much
code that's required but you still have
to get engineers to edit application
code you still have to get them to you
still have to get them to for every
endpoint ivy spans or if someone forgets
to do that then that relationship is
broken it's not as useful is there zero
touch implementation that's
well is there a way for no one to edit
code and still get the benefits of Tracy
so what yeah so at lift we did this by
using envoy so envoy is a like a proxy a
network proxy that is fraud on every
every box we use it as our front proxy
but also we use it as our proxy into for
every service so this is a sidecar C++
application that's run on every host or
every container and all network requests
goes through both egress and ingress go
through envoy so database calls go
through our Moy first and then get
called a database or goes to the
application so here's kind of the rough
architecture diagram of how it all fits
together so envoy is the program that
submitting the traces and the
application doesn't have to do anything
and then when the application makes a
call to another application it just
needs to send this header so that they
could tie those fans together and this
is this is abstracted away with network
libraries so we have envoy client
libraries for every language and all it
does is just if it sees the OT span
contacts header it will take that and
pass it along with the network request
and that envoy emits all that data via G
RPC sends all that data to the
collectors in a very efficient way a
synchronously so when we roll this out
to when we enable tree singing we just
added in one code base and rolled it out
and then every every one all the
services got tracing that are useful
right away it's just per true and if you
if people wanted to add more like
detailed spans they could do that with a
custom with open tracing libraries which
was very helpful so that was kind of
nice that was that was really awesome to
be able to change the code in one place
and standardize it in one place
roll it out to all the boxes and have
everyone get eat grass or in grass
and network traces immediately so so as
we roll this out we have all this data
but like the thing is it's another tool
that people need to use right like
people are really used to using
dashboards and looking at logs but and
changing people's workflows unless it's
like really pop unless it's really
really useful it's really hard to do to
get it it's really hard to get adoption
so well and so anyway initially we did
struggle with this because tracing is
very new the UI has some ramped up like
you kind of have to like sit down and
look at the traces to see what it means
and there's some terminology that you
have to learn in order to get the most
usefulness out of it so how what were
the challenges to getting adoption and
this is how we kind of tackled that one
is to get it integrated into people's
workflows as much as possible so
everyone knows - borz that's the main
tool that they use and so we added these
little dots that correlated a trace with
that dashboard so like for example if
there was a spike in five hundreds you
could click on this dot and it would
send you a link to a trace that was
representative of the error that you
were seeing so if you see high response
times you'll see a trace with that
latency and then you start debugging
right away and so giving people that
context was pretty powerful the second
thing we did was add it to Pedro duty
and so when when when you get a page and
if there is a trace available we all add
it into the details and what's nice
about this is like what you're woken up
in the middle of night you just want to
know what the root problem is and like
mitigate as quickly as possible and so
this was pretty useful versus like
versus before you have to look at logs
and sift through a bunch of air era logs
you look at the trace you can see which
sort of if it's your service or not
sometimes it's not your service and you
could really keep that page to the to
the owner of that application
or like you realize it's not it's like a
new feature that's being launched and
it's not a big deal and you kiss news
yeah
and so the big takeaways for this is
that like integrating with envoy was the
biggest one because that way we didn't
have to get engineers to edit their code
you could achieve something similar with
libraries but like that zero touch
experience is really nice especially if
you're supporting multiple languages you
maintaining libraries for multiple
languages is very difficult so to
minimize that effort is was a huge one
secondly it's like tying all the tooling
as much to tying all the tooling
together as much as possible it's also
really essential for adoption so people
are used to metrics and dashboards a lot
using scene logs so if you could we're
trying to come up with solutions where
we could tie tracing into those tooling
already and give so that they could take
that context from the dashboard into the
tracing tool and yeah we also have a way
for we are working on a way to display
tracing with the log associated with it
the sampling so lot that's a little bit
harder but it is possible to like be
able to show the log that was emitted
and linked to the trace that that is
associated if it's available in a second
and that's the last thing is that like
as you scale you have to start thinking
about sampling because there's just too
much data to store and sampling
strategies are really hard especially
it's very business dependent and what
data that and it's dependent on like
what what your engineers need to triage
and debug and there's no like one bullet
answered if you to say that you should
sample based upon this like and also you
can just sample randomly otherwise
you'll get incomplete traces so sampling
strategies are very hard and it's very
business dependent and something we're
soulful
hangout so yeah that's that is the end
of my talk I just feel like I scratched
the surface and there's like so much
more information I wanted to stuff in
here but I felt like it would be way too
long so there the place I linked here
there are a couple of things I think are
pretty useful to branch out one is the
open tracing homepage which is has
useful documentation and has a great
explanation of like the vocabulary and
like oh and more detailed information
about the open tracing specification the
second link I link is a tutorial where
where URI goes over he's the creator of
Jaeger and he also created these like
tutorials where you build a little micro
service you add instrumentation and you
kind of look to you look at the actual
data and see what data is getting
admitted and have a deep understanding
of like how it all fits together
secondly is the thirdly it's a diaper
paper which is the tool that Google uses
and this is what all this distributed
chasing tools are based out of it's a
very it's a it's a it's not a academic
paper it's we're very practical and it's
a pretty fun read if you have the time
to see where it all originated from and
lastly is it's a talk by Peter Alvaro
which I found really useful where if you
take you would take tracing to the next
level of like how do were to do chaos
engineering where to check fault next
using tracing data so that's it thank
you so much for coming to my talk I feel
free to ask questions on to me on
Twitter I love talking about tracing and
love to hear what how you use it or like
if you have questions about integrating
with it and feedback is always welcome
about for my talk so yeah thank you so
much
[Applause]